in a British study students were asked
whether they would allow a
self-professed witch to cast an evil hex
on them about half of them said yes four
there should be no concern if witchcraft
is actually nonsense yet the other half
of the participants said no few of the
people who said no actually believed in
witchcraft but nonetheless their
perceived superstition their doubts that
perhaps the hex could be real made them
too dubious to go ahead with it anyway
so then how about you would you allow a
haggard woman to cast a spell on you and
I'm not talking about marriage vows some
people are more superstitious than
office a person's proclivity to believe
in astrology highlights a degree of
their superstitious nature the idea that
the precise moment a person was born and
the precise alignment of the stars in
the sky at that time will determine that
person's personality on their future I'm
about to read five personality traits
that I believe will describe you
perfectly keep account of how many of
them you believe do in fact reflect you
as a person you have a tendency to be
critical of yourself you have a great
deal of unused capacity which you have
not turned to your advantage at time do
you have serious doubts as to whether
you have made the right decision or done
the right thing you prefer a certain
amount of change on variety and become
dissatisfied when hemmed in by
restrictions and limitations at times
you are extroverted affable sociable
whilst other times you are introverted
wary reserved to start sound a lot like
you yes well it also sounded a lot like
the 39 psychology students of Bertram
Forer when he gave them all a private
piece of paper that had the exact same
descriptions written on them he told
them he had personalized these
descriptions based on the unique
personality traits of every single one
of them he then asked the students to
each ray
it's their own description based on how
uniquely it describes their personality
from zero to five for accuracy five
being the most accurate the average
rating of all the students was four
point three of course fora
had lied he hadn't personalized each
student's description uniquely he hunt
even considered their personality for a
second
he stole the descriptions from the
astrology section of a magazine he had
picked up from the newsstand a week
earlier and every student's description
was exactly the same down to the letter
for have Illustrated how everyone has a
natural proclivity an innate need to
believe very broad statements that could
apply to just about everybody on the
planet especially when those statements
are complimentary or positive you are
tremendously attractive by the way other
research has shown that people who are
born in moms that typically have
positive astrological descriptions
associated with them are far more likely
to believe in astrology than those who
are born in negatively associated mumps
we all crave positivity in our lives
even at the expense of gullibility in
1956 American psychologist Paul Mele
named this effect the Barnum effect
after American showman PT Barnum if
you're sat there thinking isn't this
also how cold reading works then yes you
would be absolutely correct give
yourself a cookie the same kind of
general yet seemingly personal Barnum
statements are used profusely by
so-called psychic mediums psychologist
dr. Susan Blackmore surveyed more than
6,000 people and found that people
responded agreeably with a great number
of seemingly specific statements one
quarter of them said they had someone
named Jack in the family and more than
one-third of them said yes I do when
told you have a scar on your left knee
because the truth is a good chunk of the
population has a scar on their left knee
even if they have to search for it with
a microscope
and even someone who doesn't have any
scar would still answer yes when told
this pseudo fact by a medium because
people have an innate desire to fit in
we want to fit in especially amongst
large groups of people it's nice to fit
it that's why you tell people at parties
at your freelance writer in sort of
tragically unemployed and if you believe
that the medium is right about your
non-existent scar then you will also
believe him when he says that you're
dead Aunt Mabel has had a lot of time to
think about is being dead and all and
she has concluded that you are most
definitely her favorite grandchild there
are some incredibly stupid superstitions
around the world in Colombia it is
thought that if you sit on a chair that
is still warm from a previous occupant
you'll get a boil on your ass in Vermont
Windows is sometimes built as a
45-degree angle into the sides of houses
because it's believed that witches are
unable to fly through tilted windows but
my favorite has to be this there is an
old sailor superstition that having a
woman on board a ship it's bad luck
however if she is naked then she has the
opposite effect and calms the Seas look
we don't want you to be naked either but
we don't want to jeopardize the voyage
now do we when surveyed 13% of people
said that they would not like to stay on
the 13th floor of a hotel a nine percent
said they would definitely ask for a new
room on another level 14 percent of
people won't buy a house that is number
whether it's knocking on wood black cats
or broken mirrors we have all indulged
in a little casual superstition from
time to time but it turns out that the
reason that we do this is because some
of these common superstitions have a
basis in fact or at least we think they
do triskaidekaphobia those who have a
fear of the number 13 have good cause to
be concerned the origins of the infamy
surrounding a number 13 come from
religious mythology in Norse mythology
the mischievous and malevolent Loki was
the 13th got to sit down at a dinner
party of 12 over gods in Valhalla Loki
then kills the god of light and joy
Balder by throwing a sprig of mistletoe
at him now I've attended some tragically
boring dinner parties but that does not
sound like one of them there were also
13 present at the Last Supper and Judas
was supposedly the last the thirteenth
guests to sit down to eat there are also
modern day myths surrounding Friday the
13th there is a widely circulated story
that in the 20th century the Royal Navy
attempted to dispel the long-held
superstitions surrounding Fridays and
the number thirteen by launching a new
ship called HMS Friday it will be
captained by Rebecca Black only kidding
that would just be asking for a violent
mutiny its maiden voyage was on Friday
the 13th on the Captain James Friday but
true to superstition soon after it set
sail HMS Friday disappeared and was
never heard from again
whew the problem with this story is that
it's entirely made up there never was a
HMS Friday and anybody caught repeating
it as fact should be hit repeatedly
until they stop talking some arguably
more reputable sources however reports
that traffic incidents go up on Friday
the 13th however some other sources have
also said that traffic incidents
decrease on Friday the 13th so do you
take that fact with a pinch of salt and
don't spill it and make sure to throw it
over your left shoulder to keep the
devil away it has also been reported
though that household accidents on
Friday the 13th shoot up especially when
a gun is involved if both these examples
are true however they don't actually
give any reason to be superstitious and
I'll tell you why psychologists have
found that people who believe in unlucky
superstitions such as Friday the 13th
walking under a ladder or crossing a
black cat are far more likely to succumb
to negative effects because of these
beliefs whereas all of these
superstitious events have no
statistically significant effect to
people who are not superstitious they
are therefore self-fulfilling
Prophecy's if one believes they are more
likely to come to harm on Friday the
13th they will become stressed not think
straight and perhaps pay less attention
on the roads or at home on that day
resulting in an accident that they
unwittingly helped induce don't believe
me that people would change their daily
routine so drastically due to a number
on a certain day well it is estimated
that every Friday the 13th 900 million
dollars of business is lost in the u.s.
due to people changing their entire
daily routine and staying at home out of
fear but the self-fulfilling prophecy
phenomenon doesn't explain the fact that
in the UK national lottery in which
balls are supposedly drawn randomly the
number 13 is the least drawn ball of all
time a huge coincidence or evidence of
some higher power you decide Harvard
psychologist BF Skinner explained why
humans are superstitious in the mid 20th
century through the cunning use of
pigeons he placed several pigeons in
sensory deprivation boxes plain boxes
where no outside stimulus could affect
their behavior Skinner
proceeded to drop food into the boxes at
completely random intervals there was
absolutely no logic to when the pigeons
would receive food but curiously it
didn't appear that way to the pigeons
they grew superstitious and started to
believe that whatever action they were
doing when they first received food
somehow caused them to receive food
again if they repeated that passion if
the pigeon happened to be flapping its
wings when it received food then it
would flap its wings again until it got
more food over pigeons exhibited more
unusual behavior some wood twister had
repeatedly at awkward angles another
frost its head repeatedly into the upper
corner of the box
another would pirouette doing spins over
and over again until it received food BF
Skinner had made his pigeons
superstitious he concluded that there
was no difference in the behavior
between these pit
and not of a professional footballer who
thinks that wearing their lucky socks
somehow helps them to score more goals
Skinner
have demonstrated the basic premise
behind superstition patterns the pigeons
were making connections finding patterns
wherever they could
between ostensibly trivial actions and
the result of getting fed humans do this
all the time when we knock on wood
sometimes something good happens this
strengthens the connection in our mind
between knocking on wood and a positive
outcome yet the other phenomenon known
as confirmation bias where we only pay
attention to positive outcomes makes us
disregard the many times we knocked on
wood and absolutely nothing good or
actually something bad happened I wish I
could answer the superstition question
with some profound Universal statements
but ultimately the answer lies in a
pissing pigeon and you know what I think
there's a certain beauty in that I've
just launched my first book stick if I
can it's a thousand years of bizarre
history from Britain and beyond it's
witty fun and damn interesting
I'm crowdfunding it through unbound
publishing it would absolutely mean the
world to me if you pledged to help make
this book a reality and in return you
can get a signed first edition hardback
copy as soon as it's printed so please
head on over to unbound watch the launch
video over there read the first two
chapters for free and if you like it
then pledge to secure your copy today
the links in a description thank you so
much